[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'est l'heure de
politique à table sur LCP on se retrouve
avec un invité autour d'un plat et d'un
dessert et aujourd'hui nous recevons
Hervé Berville bonjour bonjour et merci
de l'invitation merci d'avoir accepté et
évidemment avec moi pour présenter cette
émission Jean-Pierre Montanez bonjour
Jean-Pierre bonjour Hervé Berville
bonjour vous êtes secrétaire d'État à la
mère depuis juillet 2022 député des
Côtes-d'Armor vous avez été élu en 2017
et réélu en 2022 vous vous engagez dès
2015 auprès d'Emmanuel Macron vous êtes
le référent de la macronie dans votre
département et chargez de défendre dans
votre région le programme écho vous qui
êtes diplômé d'une maîtrise en histoire
économique à la prestigieuse London
School a fait économics vous êtes
originaire du Rwanda à 4 ans vous êtes
adopté par une famille de plus d'une eau
c'est à 30 km de Saint-Malo dans les
Côtes-d'Armor la Bretagne donc la mer
qui a largement inspiré le déjeuner du
jour grillé
le petit légumes et on desserre des
crêpes à la confiture de cerises dans le
dessous des plats les bulots ont chaud
et résultat ils se font plus rares et
plus chers on vous embarque à la pêche
en Seine-Maritime dans les pieds dans
plat le désarroi de ces pêcheurs bretons
français même piégé par le brexit il ne
peuvent plus pêcher dans les eaux
britanniques alors que faire de leur
bateau reportage à suivre allez on passe
à table tout de suite cuisine et
confidence
Hervé Berville au moment où votre pays
d'origine s'ouvre tout risque vous
auriez pu nous faire découvrir les
spécialités du Rwanda rien que pour le
plaisir j'encule qui nous a fait saliver
avec Brigitte ligi safulia c'est un
ragoût de poulet plein de saveurs avec
des bananes plantain des feuilles de
manioc mais ce n'est pas avec la
promotion d'un d'une telle recette sans
produit de la mer que vous pouvez
scander votre fameuse déclaration
d'amour je veux rendre un la Bretagne ce
qu'elle m'a donné et elle vous a
notamment donné la mer et ses richesses
ces produits vous qui incarnez tellement
bien cette chanson de Renaud c'est pas
l'homme qui prend la mer c'est la mère
qui prend l'homme
vous la mère elle nous a donc pris je me
souviens un lundi de juillet 2022 quand
vous avez été nommé ministre de la mer
donc le poisson et en l'occurrence ce
rouget c'est votre totem culinaire un
peu votre label breton et marin mais là
où je ne vous comprends plus monsieur le
ministre c'est quand vous précisez un
rouget de Méditerranée alors là la
Bretagne risque de mal prendre cette
trahison
c'est pour monter mon caractère inclusif
et que on est ministre de la mer de
toutes les façades maritimes non parce
que je me suis dit l'occasion fait de la
rond et vu que j'ai l'opportunité de me
faire offrir un déjeuner et que je
connais moins les produits de la pêche
issus de la Méditerranée j'ai souhaité
mettre à l'honneur aussi les produits de
la pêche de la Méditerranée parce que on
a la chance d'avoir en France des
façades littorales splendides d'abord et
puis qui ont des pêches très différentes
et donc notamment les Méditerranéens
j'étais la semaine dernière dans le Var
dans les Alpes-Maritimes et à Marseille
la semaine encore avant ils sont très
attachés à ces spécificités
méditerranéennes je serai la semaine
prochaine aussi en Corse et puis les
Bretons voilà c'est les poissons que je
connais mieux bouger en Bretagne
et Atlantique c'est pour ça voilà je
marche sur les deux jambes voilà mais
c'est pour vous montrer que on peut
avoir une diversité de produits sur nos
façades littor et on a une chance
incroyable parce que il y a peu de pays
en Europe il y a peu de pays dans le
monde qui ont cette diversité des
produits de la mer je pense également
bien évidemment à la conchiliculture à
l'aquaculture à l'ostréiculture bref on
a une qualité un savoir-faire crois
qu'il faut entretenir qu'il faut
reconnaître qu'il faut valoriser donc
c'est pour ça que vous savez que j'étais
breton il y avait un dessert breton je
me suis dit je vais prendre un poisson
méditerranéen mais est-ce que vous avez
été élevé véritablement ou poisson à
justement toutes ces
coquillages qu'on trouve près de chez
vous non j'ai appris à les connaître
d'abord je suis né dans un pays vous
l'avez dit pour le coup exactement qui
n'a pas d'accès à la mer comme quoi tout
peut arriver et on peut aimer à à la mer
au fil des années et
j'ai grandi à plus d'une eau donc c'est
une commune rurale mon grand-père était
agriculteur la moitié de ma famille est
dans l'agriculture et en fait dans les
Côtes-d'Armor comme un peu partout
d'ailleurs en Bretagne c'est entre terre
et mer c'est la mort l'Argoat et donc il
y a aussi ces ce qui me m’intéresse
aussi dans cette mission c'est de faire
découvrir aussi la mer à des gens qu'il
n'y avait pas trop trop loin par exemple
mon grand-père
lui il a grandi toute sa vie
10 km de la mer jamais ça lui aurait
venu à l'esprit d'aller l'été sur la
plage c'était quelque chose pour lui les
vacances c'était plutôt dans la vallée
ou à la campagne et donc on voit bien
que c'est pas parce que vous habitez à
côté de la mer que vous y allez
régulièrement et donc il y a un vrai
nestit d'avoir une politique publique
aussi notamment sur les classes de mer
quand vous étiez petit moi je fais
partie de cette génération qui
contrairement à nos grands-parents
passer beaucoup plus j'ai fait des
classes de mer j'étais animateur
centre aéré donc on allait quasiment
tous les deux jours à la mer et puis
surtout enfin moi la mer ça a été comme
beaucoup d’ailleurs un vrai espace de
d'abord de rêve de liberté
d'imaginaire parce que quand vous voyez
cette grande étendue vous demandez
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de le goût alors
c'était pas ma grande joie
j'ai le pied marin mais c'était pas là
où j'excellais j'étais plutôt basket
football mais c'est vrai que prendre la
mer et puis voir aussi tous ces exploits
moi je me rappelle très bien ma première
année je suis arrivé en France en 1994
[Musique]
ou en tout cas événement que mes parents
m'ont amené c'était la Route du Rhum le
départ de la Route du
rhumilier c'est millions de gens moi
j'étais au Cap Fréhel parce que au Cap
Fréhel dans ma circonscription vous
voyez le départ de la Route du Rhum et
c'était juste un manège splendide et
donc c'est là que je me suis rendu
compte que les Bretons étaient quand
même très attachés à ce littoral à cette
mère et puis rien de mieux que faire un
foot sur la plage l'été avec les copains
aussi alors je reviendrai au rouge à
quand même parce que j'ai dit vous êtes
inclusif mais le rouge est alors vous
allez me dire vous êtes l'expert moi
j'ai aussi pensé que le rouge et vous
leur prendriez dans l'Atlantique parce
que de ce que je comprends il est moins
victime de la surpêche qu'en
Méditerranée est-ce que c'est vrai ou
pas parce que les chiffres de l'ifère de
la dernière fournée sont un peu
compliquées à lire oui est-ce que le
rouge est un poisson durable oui le
rouge est un poisson durable mais il
faut toujours
travailler pour augmenter la durabilité
de tous nos différents stocks exactement
et chaque année à l'Union européenne
parce que vous savez que la pêche c'est
une politique communautaire donc c'est
une politique de l'Union européenne
les pays se mettent d'accord sur des
quotas de pêche en fonction des façades
maritimes ce qui limite bien évidemment
la surface mais surtout ce qui est fait
dans l'intérêt des pêcheurs et que les
pêcheurs aussi portent comme politique
pour dire il il faut qu'on arrive à
gérer le stock pour avoir encore bien
évidemment des poissons dans les dans
les années après et pour les futures
générations et un très bel exemple alors
qui est au delà des quotas de pêche à
l'Union européenne mais c'est ce qui se
passe par exemple sur les coquilles la
coquille Saint-Jacques au large de ma
magnifique circonscription en Bretagne
ou encore en Normandie en l'espace de 15
ans les pêcheurs exactement ont triplé
la ressource parce que on leur a fait
confiance parce qu'ils sont basés sur
les données sur la science parce qu'ils
ont préservé l'habitat marin exactement
renouveler et donc là on a un produit
d'une grande qualité un produit qui est
reconnu dans le monde entier et un
produit qui est bien géré alors goûter
et pendant ce temps là Jean-Pierre vous
vous doutez pas vous exprimer
et d'hydroger trois choses à savoir sur
le rouge et Jean-Pierre bon merci
Brigitte alors vite l'appellation rouget
ne doit être utilisée que pour désigner
le rouget barbet mais ça monsieur
ministre doit le savoir
identifiable grâce à ses Lombards qui
sont près de sa bouche et puis ces
couleurs vives et pas pour le grondin
rouge ni pour le rouge à du Sénégal donc
attention hein le rouge est c'est un mot
particulier qui a tendance à être
galvaudé dans ces deux cas il y a donc
tromperie le rouge et Barbet est présent
dans l'océan Atlantique est de la
Norvège jusqu'au Sénégal même et les
îles Canaries y compris donc on l'a dit
en Méditerranée et même je l'ai
découvert en mer Noire alors deux pour
la cuisson le four est souvent l'option
numéro 1 attention le rouge a une
certaine délicate donc pas plus de 15
minutes à 180 degrés autre option la
papillote dans du papier aluminium ou
cuisson ajouter la des épices des
aromates enfournez 10 grosses minutes à
170 degrés et puis il y a aussi le
rouget à la poêle je pense que c'est
comme ça que notre restaurateur la
préparé avec un peu d'huile d'olive on
fait légèrement grillé la peau puis on
le retourne et on le fait cuire 5
minutes voilà 5 minutes
alors comment l'accompagner le rouge est
facile il se marie très vite avec du riz
des petits légumes au pistou des légumes
comme ça des courgettes des pommes de
terre des tomates à la provençale avec
du persil de l'ail et le citron confit
ou pas et toujours bienvenu avec le
rougey Hervé Berville ce rouge il est
bon ou pas
splendide splendide il est à votre goût
est-ce que vous voulez
parfaitement cuit et voyez j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses parce que je dois
l'admettre je ne sais pas comment
parfaitement cuire le rouget
j'aime bien cuisiner j'ai beaucoup moins
le temps
je suis plutôt dessert
j'ai la chance d'avoir un frère qui est
chef cuisinier qui m'a du coup dispensé
de travailler la matière au cours des
années et puis quatre frères et sœurs
qui sont d'excellents aussi cuisiniers
et cuisinier entre qui adore ça donc moi
je suis un peu qu'est-ce que vous savez
faire vous avez de la famille en la
matière
quand même si Jean-Pierre et moi on
vient dîner chez vous qu'est-ce que vous
nous préparez je pense son entrée un
petit taboulé
j'aime beaucoup ça
moule pas le vrai taboulé libanais avec
de l'herbe d'accord
tout ce que vous connaissez bien
ensuite qu'est-ce que je pourrais vous
faire bon ça peut être du lieu ou alors
si c'est une viande ça peut être
la côte de porc ça vient de découvrir
chez moi j'aime beaucoup les pommes de
terre c'est très simple c'est toujours
bon on sera jamais et puis en dessert
bon on en mangera tout à l'heure mais
c'est des crêpes mais j'adore le
clafoutis clafoutis pruneaux ou tarte à
la rhubarbe et est-ce que c'est très
simple à faire c'est exquis et j'ai
aussi un petit faible pour les tartes
aux figues et aucune recette d'Afrique
parce que j'ai fait allusion tout à
l'heure à une heure j'ai trouvé que
genre en cherchant il y a une vraie
tradition gastronomique au Rwanda vous
connaissez bien d'ailleurs
spécialité culinaire je suis arrivé à
quand j'avais 4 ans donc avant 4 ans on
se rappelle de peu de choses et puis
c'était un contexte qui était très lourd
puisque c'était au moment du génocide
des Tutsi et donc je me suis pas plongé
dans l'histoire culinaire du Rwanda mais
quand j'y suis retourné j'ai eu
l'occasion de de goûter un certain
nombre de plats
je dois dire et c'est pas faire offense
à la cuisine rwandaise que je préfère la
cuisine française et la cuisine bretonne
le meilleur du monde donc c'est
compliqué l'une des meilleures du monde
c'est celle que je connais la mieux mais
en tout cas il y a on vous le voyez dans
beaucoup de restaurants maintenant il y
a cette beaucoup de fusion ça date du
certain nombre d'années mais entre la
cuisine dite africaine parce que en fait
l'Afrique c'est très vaste beaucoup de
pays donc on peut pas caractériser la
cuisine africaine et puis la cuisine
méditerranéenne ou européenne même si
bien évidemment en Afrique que vous avez
Maghreb qui est méditerranéen et puis il
y a aussi maintenant vous avez peut-être
déjà vu ça de la fusion entre de la
cuisine japonaise et puis de la cuisine
qui vient du Sénégal il y a des
restaurants à Paris comme ça je me
rappelle plus long j'ai testé c'est
délicieux donc j'aime bien aussi c'est
mélanges c'est une manière d'appréhender
une cuisine une tradition et vous vous
fusionnez la Bretagne et l'Afrique du
coup dans votre assiette de temps en
temps non très
très très peu je fusionne plus l'aspect
méditerranéen avec la Bretagne alors
après quand j'étais vécu j'ai quand j'ai
vécu j'ai vécu au Mozambique pendant 2
ans qui a un pays splendide et il
faisait ce qu'ils appelaient des
camaradesh c'est des des crevettes
délicieuses bon ça j'ai essayé de
l'importer mais c'est jamais aussi bien
fait que que là on l'a on l'a vu dans
les Côtes d'Armor mais crevettes très
fraîches mais c'est la manière de le
faire c'est la préparation donc non mais
c'est quelque chose peut-être que quand
j'aurai beaucoup plus de temps libre
peut-être que je m'essaierai à
expérimenter la fusion entre le Rwanda
et puis la France après moi j'ai
forcément un attachement à ce pays j'ai
eu la chance que le Président de la
République me nomme envoyé spécial
pendant les 25e commémorations du
génocide donc c'était un moment
forcément qui c'était très fort et moi
je suis assez comment dire très
intéressé par la manière dont un pays se
sort d'un drame aussi terrible vous
imaginez millions de personnes qui ont
été massacrées en l'espace d'un mois
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas bien
cette histoire c'est presque quelques
mois un million en un mois à la machette
donc l'horreur au-delà du du nombre et
qui arrive en moins de deux décennies à
se relever à être un exemple pour
beaucoup de pays africains sur le
développement bien évidemment il y a
comme dans beaucoup de pays des
problèmes qui persistent et puis c'est
cette réconciliation c'est fascinant de
voir que par exemple avec ce qu'on
appelle les tribunaux gatcha en fait
Concorde ceux qui avaient perpétré le
génocide vu qu'il y avait pas assez de
place dans les prisons il y a eu ce sont
inspirés des tribunaux traditionnels et
il faisait plutôt des travaux que
d'aller en prison donc la manière dont
en effet la Concorde la paix civile a
été retrouvée même si personne n'oublie
on reconstruit pas à pas fil après fil
le tissu social de ce pays moi je trouve
ça remarquable donc je dois avouer que
ça m'intéresse beaucoup plus que que la
nourriture mais je m'y intéresserais et
je reviendrai peut-être ici en vous
proposant cette fusion là si on revient
un petit peu à l'alimentation la
nourriture qui nous occupe leur destinée
est-ce que vous vous aimez par exemple
faire le marché choisir vos fruits vos
légumes vous disiez mais mes
grands-parents étaient mauvais de
grand-père était agriculteurs qu'est-ce
qui cultivait ce que vous vous avez un
peu cette attachement à la terre ou pas
où j'habite parents habitent à plus je
suis entouré de champ donc
c'est pas un attachement ça va au-delà
de ça c'est c'est constitutif de
[Musique]
mes souvenirs et de ce que je suis en
fait mon grand-père c'était pas un
jardin qui avait lui c'était un champ
quasiment parce qu'il avait été
agriculteur donc on s'est mis à la
retraite en fait il a gardé une grande
parcelle de terre et cultiver tout
des courgettes des melons il avait au
fond du de son jardin des cerises des
petits pois des carottes et on devait
écouter l'été je me rappelle les
haricots donc on avait en plus vu qu'il
avait 4 enfants en général il faisait
une production comme s'il avait encore
ses quatre filles à la maison donc du
coup on avait la chance d'avoir mais
sauf que ça demande du travail le
jardinage parce que quand vous avez des
pommes de terre bah faut s'en occuper
après faut les dégermer donc ça se passe
en hiver pour éviter que les grandes
pousses donc quand vous avez 500 g de
patates ça va quand vous avez quasiment
20 25 kg de pommes de terre dans le
froid en novembre en Bretagne c'est pas
la même histoire donc non moi le les les
meilleurs moments que j'ai passé avec
mon grand-père c'était quand on allait
l'aider très modestement et j'imagine
pas de la manière la plus efficace dans
le jardin qu'on était petit parce que
voilà ça permet de passer du temps avec
lui et ma grand-mère et puis en fait moi
j'ai jamais vécu autre chose que d'avoir
des produits dans ma famille
des produits du jardin simplement
autosuffisant donc chez vous bon non on
a acheté des choses qu'on avait pas
forcément mais tout ce que je vais voilà
que ce soit aussi les les
potimarron les potirons pour faire des
soupes l'hiver enfin le gros de la
cuisine familiale était fourni congelé
par les congelés au jardin l'été
carottes même en congé des cerises on
devait écouter des cerises hop on les
mettait dans des sacs et comme ça
clafoutis aux cerises l'hiver vous avez
un petit coup de moule l'hiver vous
faites la préparation vous vous prenez
décongeler les sacs de cerises alors ça
perd un peu de sa saveur bien évidemment
mais c'est voilà et c'est des produits
du jardin et pareil pour tout ce qui est
courgettes alors melon non vous congelez
pas les melons mais
pas du tout et du coup vous êtes très
attachés à l'agriculture conventionnelle
ou vous dites aujourd'hui il faut manger
du bio il faut cultiver naturellement
sans pesticides
je dis que l'agriculture telle qu'elle a
été développée nous a permis la
souveraineté alimentaire et les
agriculteurs ont eu à s'adapter à ce
qu'on leur a demandé il fallait nourrir
la population il fallait nourrir ce qui
me concerne ce que je connais mieux la
Bretagne et au fil des années c'est
eux-mêmes qui souvent ont proposé des
adaptations et bien évidemment qu'on ne
pratique plus l'agriculture aujourd'hui
comme à la pratiquait il y a 45 ans et
donc moi il faut de tout c'est comme
dans une forêt un écosystème ça a besoin
de tout il y a besoin d'avoir de
l'agriculture des conventionnelles parce
qu'on a besoin d'avoir des volumes pour
fournir les cantiques scolaires pour
fournir les les hôpitaux on a besoin
scolaires se met tout au bio donc oui
mais
ils essayent toutes bien sûr on en est
loin encore des objectifs elles essaient
de tendre vers le bio et non pas vers le
conventionnel mais bien évidemment mais
du bio si c'est du bio qui a importé
d'Espagne ça n'a aucun sens donc le ce
qui est important c'est où ça se situe
c'est que ce soit du circuit court
qui est important et puis il faut pas
tomber dans les caricatures c'est à dire
que nos agriculteurs au-delà de
participer aussi à la gestion de de
l'environnement font un travail qui est
remarquable c'est très tôt le matin
termine très tard le soir et donc il y a
toujours des adaptations c'est comme
pour les pêcheurs c'est comme pour le
métier de journaliste c'est comme pour
le métier de politique vous ne faites
pas de la même manière que vous le
faisiez il y a 50 ans mais je crois
qu'il faut vraiment reconnaître leur
travail et et pas jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain c'est à dire que parce que
et c'est nécessité nous devons renforcer
la protection de l'environnement la
protection de la biodiversité c'est vrai
dans tous les domaines l'industrie
l'agriculture
l'activité économique le commerce va
tous les secteurs sont engagés dedans
que moi j'ai un infini respect pour les
agriculteurs parce que je les ai vu
travailler au quotidien mon grand-père
l'été
suffisamment les agriculteurs pour les
aider dans cette transition l'année
dernière par exemple
dans les Côtes-d'Armor nous avons
accompagné c'était Julien en Normandie
qui était ministre agriculture à
l'époque avec un plan à hauteur de 215
millions d'euros des producteurs les
producteurs de port parce qu'ils vivent
une crise qui était lié à l'augmentation
du coup de l'énergie pour faire en sorte
qu'on est encore cette souveraineté
alimentaire parce que qui peut
comprendre qu'on continuerait à apporter
des produits qui n'ont même pas du tout
les mêmes standards que nous et donc il
faut le redire aussi nous avons la pêche
la plus contrôlée la plus exigeante du
monde nous avons l'agriculture la plus
contrôlée la plus exigeante du monde
dans le cas notamment du Robin et on a
souvent été taxé de surtransposer c'est
à dire que au Parlement on a des règles
encore plus dures que ce qui est une
européen et moi je le constate tous les
jours quand je me déplace je vois bien
que dans d'autres pays c'est pas du tout
la même chose ça suffit pas en termes
dans l'agriculture
la dynamique l'évolution et puis
regardez quelle est la cause par exemple
de l'effondrement des stocks de de pêche
dans le monde c'est pas la paix
française c'est la surpêche qui vient
des navires
de pays asiatiques ce qui menace la
biodiversité marine ce n'est pas la
pêche artisanale côtière française c'est
les risques par exemple d'exploitation
minière des fonds
de la négociation du sommet sur le
Traité des Nations Unies pour les océans
pour la protection de la haute mer
pardon et on avait fait une conférence
de presse commune on s'est bien entendu
et on s'était dit qu'un jour on
souhaiterait faire une tribune sur un
autre sujet que celui la protection de
la haute mer la haute mer juste pour
vous dire c'est
60% des océans donc la haute mer c'est
45% de la surface de notre planète donc
si on veut protéger les océans si on
protège la biodiversité marine et si on
veut protéger l'environnement parce que
les océans sont importants pour la
protection de l'environnement on doit
protéger à votre mère et après 15 ans de
négociation 15 ans de négociation
c'était dans les abysses des discussions
onusiennes le président de la République
a relancé cet accord ce traité onusien
en 2022 il m'a demandé d'en faire une
priorité je me suis rendu trois fois
à New York et grâce à le numéro
européenne grâce à l'engagement de la
France et du président de la République
nous avons il y a une semaine adoptée
cet accord qui est majeur pour la
protection exactement c'est vraiment
faut voir le pacser parce que c'est 45%
de la surface de la planète qui est
protégée je m'éloigne
que vous nous avez demandé c'est un vin
de Bourgogne en appellation haute-côte
de nuit donc c'est on est au nord de la
Bourgogne à l'ouest de l'appellation
côte de nuit près de votre Romanée ou de
Nuits-Saint-Georges on a un millésime
2021 le cépage c'est évidemment du pinot
noir et la particularité alors c'était
une robe un peu violacée pour vous
Jean-Pierre assez intense et il a un nez
un peu fruité
[Musique]
alors vous le Breton vous le savez sans
doute d'adoption certes la sardine a
longtemps été l'un des poissons rois de
la Bretagne et c'est ici en Bretagne
dans votre territoire qu'est né la boîte
de sardines à l'huile que le monde nous
envie à cette fameuse boîte de sardines
seriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sont vraies ou fausses
avant d'être rangé dans les boîtes vous
pouvez lire là avant d'être rangé dans
les boîtes les sardines sont salées
faux effectivement elles sont
ébouillantes et ensuite elles sont
rangées les unes à côté des autres avec
de l'huile d'olive les boîtes de
sardines en fer blanc c'est une
invention ça ont été inventés par les
Britanniques vrai ou faux
[Musique]
ça je pense que c'est
je pense que c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
et donc du coup ils ont apporté un peu
de leur savoir-faire dans cette
confection des sardines en boîte puisque
les sardines étaient bretonnes mais les
boîtes étaient britanniques au 19e
siècle la sardine en boîte made in
France s'impose dans le monde entier
comme un aliment de grande consommation
et bon marché
c'est vrai non c'est faux c'est faux
manger des sardines à l'époque était un
luxe et un signe de distinction comme
boire du bordeaux donc la sardine à
l'huile dans sa petite boîte à ce siècle
là c'était un produit de luxe mais enfin
pour concurrencer les Français qui
monopolisaient le marché de la sardine
en boîte une société allemande a
commercialisé des sardines sous le nom
de sous-piquet pour faire du mal à l'un
des leaders du marché français Saupiquet
c'est vrai ou c'est faux sous piquet
contre Saupiquet
une petite bague je dirais c'est faux et
ben ça c'est vrai
alors vous allez pouvoir vous rattraper
avec ce second quiz on va voir 50
on va voir si le Breton que vous êtes
est incollable sur le bulot le bulot va
d'ailleurs en reparler un petit peu plus
tard dans cette émission alors
sauriez-vous nous dire d'où viennent ces
surnoms suivants à calicoco est-ce que
ça vient de la somme du Québec du
Cotentin ou du Finistère comment on
appelle finalement le bulot
le Cali coco Finistère
vous l'avez jamais entendu
c'est pas très loin mais c'est pas chez
vous Cotentin
[Musique]
finition Québec ou Finistère Finistère
très bien ça c'est chez moi
alors non c'est le Québec et le chanteur
est ma c'est la somme d'accord
[Rires]
vous savez qu'en France le repas a
occupe une HP large place et c'est
souvent à table que ce nous les deals
politiques et que se fait la grande
histoire c'est la brève de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé à weberville de
réfléchir à une anecdote politique
autour d'un repas est-ce que vous avez
un souvenir à nous raconter
je crois que le souvenir de et vous avez
raison de dire que dans la vie politique
mais nous on avait la tradition et on a
encore la tradition de ma famille de
faire de longs repas le dimanche en
famille
je crois que c'était un repas à la fois
savoureux et en même temps c'était vu
que c'était une première je dirais pas
que c'était douloureux mais
c'est pas celui qui restera gravé dans
mémoire comme une expérience gustative
incroyable et donc c'était au tout début
de ma campagne électorale en 2017 et
donc je vais sur un port et j'avais dit
que j'aimais bien manger que j'aimais
des produits de la mer et que bien
évidemment soupe de poisson
[Musique]
poisson et autres fruits de mer
j'adorais ça sauf que ils avaient oublié
de me préciser que c'était à 5h du matin
tandis moi je suis plutôt quelqu'un de
très très salé le matin
très très salé pardon très très sucré
vous voyez le petit déjeuner futur vous
dire que ça a été un moment assez
compliqué mais en même temps parce que
c'est des bons produits je les ai mangés
mais c'est pas quelque chose que je
reproduis dans la campagne électorale et
maintenant je demande à chaque fois
qu'on proposait non pas qu'est-ce qu'on
mange à quelle heure on le mange parce
qu'il y a pas de souci de manger des
fruits de mer mais quand ça 5 heures du
matin c'est un peu plus compliqué pour
moi en tout cas ça fait partie aussi de
des des Carnets de campagne en tout cas
des moments sympathiques dans les
campagnes
électorales c'est où on casse la croûte
je me rappelle d'un d'un
repas aussi avec un conseiller régional
de Bretagne on faisait la campagne de
2017 et on avait pas mangé depuis le
matin et en fait on s'est arrêté chez un
des militants il avait plus rien à
manger chez lui on a juste un petit bout
de pâté juste de l'eau gazeuse on va
manger ça à minuit à première partie
faire 3 heures de route à côté mais on
s'en rappelle encore parce que c'était
des bons moments où on partage quelque
chose et au fond c'est c'est vrai que la
politique est très liée à la gastronomie
en France et d'ailleurs quand je me
déplace dans les différents territoires
les pêcheurs sont toujours très fiers de
me montrer ce qu'il
ce qu'il pêche les conchyliculteurs
c'est pareil les
ce serait cutter c'est la même chose et
on a vraiment la chance au fil des
pérégrinations ministérielle de pouvoir
goûter toute la diversité et et à la
richesse de on va parler spécifiquement
du Bulot ce coquillage qu'on trouve
souvent sur les tables à Noël mais pas
seulement ils se font rares mais pour
quelle raison c'est le dessous des plats
le bulot serait-il victime du
réchauffement climatique ou est-ce la
surpêche qui le rend plus rare Jérôme
aborde son chalutier doit désormais
parcourir des milles et des milles
nautiques supplémentaires pour espérer
en attraper pierre Beretta a embarqué
pour une partie de pêche avec Maïté
le bateau en route à 5h charger les
appâts et
puis on est parti aussitôt quoi
quand on arrive près d'été on va de plus
en plus loin parce que les eaux je
réchauffent et la levure il s'en va en
fait il s'en savent pour garder de la
fraîcheur
en 24 ans les réveils de Jérôme n'ont
jamais été aussi matinée ce matin pour
trouver ce Bulot si rare le pécheur
navigra pendant une heure et demie en
haute mer c'est pas une question de
surpêche je pense que le réel problème
il est là c'est c'est le réchauffement
climatique peut rien faire pour ça
un peu de surpêche mais majoritairement
une eau qui se réchauffe et une espèce
marine qui se réduit l'Institut de
recherche pour l'exploitation de la mère
le confirme Tilo dépasse les 16 degrés
le mollusque se reproduit deux à trois
fois moins bien avant on arrivait à
faire notre quota de
aujourd'hui on va tourner aux alentours
de 600 kg quoi mais ce quota a été
révolu depuis le début de l'année il est
passé à 648 kilos par an et par bateau à
peu près l'équivalent de ce que le
pêcheur ramène dans ses casiers
alors le bulot est-il en train de
devenir un produit de luxe au port de
Dieppe voici marine on vous appelle
comment
madame Bulot j'ai le droit ou la
bulottière je vais voir ma petite
bulottière ou madame Bulot marine est la
femme de Jérôme tous les jours elle vend
la pêche de son mari et ses clients sont
les premiers témoins de la hausse du
prix du Bulot avant les avait à 4 roues
et maintenant ils sont à 6 le Quino
trop cher et on envoyait pas beaucoup à
certains endroits le prix au kilo a même
été multiplié par deux en un an le bulot
arrivera-t-il à s'adapter à la chaleur
aux migrera t-il dans des eaux plus
froides aujourd'hui en France 30 tonnes
de bulots son péchés chaque jour
[Musique]
Hervé Berville est-ce que les pêcheurs
vous ont alerté sur le fait qu'il y
avait moins de bulots ou est-ce que
vous-même vous l'avez constaté
je l'ai constaté ils m'ont alerté et
c'est un sujet de à la fois de
préoccupation mais qui démontre la
nécessité qu'on a aussi sur tous les
pans de notre activité de notre économie
à lutter contre le changement climatique
que c'est le combat premier avec l'enjeu
aussi la souveraineté économique que
nous devons porter collectivement c'est
le cas du Bulot mais on voit aussi du
fait du réchauffement climatique des
espèces nouvelles qui apparaissent donc
là qui disparaissent
le pêcheur qu'on entend il dit c'est pas
une question de surpêche est-ce qu'il
est dans le déni moi j'ai parlé de
réchauffement climatique non c'est une
réalité est-ce que je voulais dire c'est
est-ce que le péchant n'est pas dans le
déni pas du tout non non il y a c'est
prouvé scientifiquement qui a des
espèces qui qui migrent donc qui vont
dans d'autres endroits et donc pas
forcément là où il pêchait parce que il
y a du réchauffement climatique et
qu'elle préfère soit des eaux plus
froides soit des eaux plus chaudes vous
constatez par exemple que il y a du thon
rouge qu'on peut pêcher dans des
endroits où on empêcha jamais parce que
les tons migrent il y a des espèces
aussi tout à l'heure Saint-Jacques aime
la les eaux plus chaudes elles se
reproduisent
par exemple le crabe bleu en
Méditerranée alors ça c'est pas collier
au réchauffement climatique mais on voit
une multiplication de certaines espèces
et puis je vais vous prendre le cas dans
ma circonscription dans les
Côtes-d'Armor ou les producteurs de
moules ont vu en raison on pense parce
qu'on n'a pas encore toutes les études
solides c'est pour ça qu'on a lancé un
travail j'ai demandé à l'Ifremer et puis
ça risque de mon mystère de lancer des
études pour bien comprendre aussi les
causes de
cette multiplication des dorades et en
fait des dorades qui mangent toutes les
moules et donc vous avez des producteurs
de moules qui voient depuis c'est arrivé
en l'espace d'un an et demi deux ans
l'intégralité de leurs pieux
qui est mangé par des dorades et puis
maintenant il y a une nouvelle espèce
qui arrive c'est des araignées au début
c'est des circonscrits qui disparaît
finalement on ne sait pas encore
c'est des eaux qui se réchauffent et
peut-être que du coup les dorades vont
dans ces eaux qui sont réchauffés ou
alors en effet c'est les eaux qui se
réchauffent et donc le prédateur de la
dorade bref on ne sait pas exactement
parce que la brutalité à laquelle c'est
arrivé bon d'abord ça demande une
réponse d'urgence et pour les coûts
comme on dit en bon grand breton c'est
le point de bascule il suffit de ce
quelques petits degrés pour faire passer
dans une dans notre ère et et faire que
des espèces apparaissent ou de poules en
Bretagne
les homards etc c'est dû à quoi ça c'est
pareil c'est il y a
réchauffement climatique et puis il y a
des causes est-ce que c'est de la
pollution est-ce que c'est des causes
qu'on ne connaît pas encore totalement
et qui font que et bien les prédateurs
disparaissent donc les poules se
multiplient en tout cas ça ça demande
trois réponses 1 la connaissance la
science c'est fondamental c'est pour ça
que tout ce qu'on doit faire dans la
politique de lutte contre le changement
climatique et de préservation de la
biodiversité ça doit se faire sur la
science à connaissance et nous nous
vraiment c'est la volonté du Président
de la République et la première ministre
c'est de vraiment renforcer cette
dimension scientifique pour éviter les
populistes ou les caricatures ou de
stigmateur 2 c'est s'adapter et donc
c'est anticiper aussi et donc quand on
parle par exemple d'espèces invasives et
bien il faut prévoir les quotas où il
faut réduire augmenter en fonction de la
réalité des stocks on le fera sur la
science et puis trois c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est qu'il faut
avoir une attention
[Musique]
de chaque instant de chaque jour sur le
changement climatique et donc c'est à
décarbonation de tous les secteurs c'est
la préservation des habitats et c'est de
l'investissement sur cette politique
climatique c'est ce que nous faisons
depuis plus de 10 ans maintenant et on
voit bien qu'il faut continuer à
accélérer en veillant quand on fait tout
ça à avoir des activités économiques
notamment des activités de pêche parce
que c'est essentiel pour la souveraineté
alimentaire de notre pays ça fait partie
des traditions ça fait partie de
l'héritage que nous ont légué nos
grands-pères et et nos parents et donc
avoir des activités notamment de pêche
d'aquaculture de conchyliculture sur nos
littoraux c'est essentiel pour avoir
cette autonomie stratégique parce que
nous ne pouvons pas dépendre à 80% comme
c'est le cas encore des importations de
produits de la pêche et on voit bien
avec la guerre en Ukraine que être
dépendant sur des sujets aussi
stratégiques c'est une folie vous vous
dites c'est pas à cause de la surpêche
qu'il y a moins de bulots par exemple il
y a des quotas qui ont été mis en place
qui ont divisé à peu près par deux c'est
ce que nous dit Jérôme le volume en fait
de pêche de Bulot c'est c'est quota ils
vont permettre finalement à l'espèce de
ce de ce renouveler ou vous n'en êtes
pas certain en fait
c'est pas moi je c'est pas moi qui dit
ce qu'il faut faire pas tout ce qu'on
fait c'est basé sur la science il y a
des avis scientifiques qui sont donnés
sur
tout un tas d'espèces et chaque année
l'Union européenne sur les stocks de
lieu de bars
[Musique]
scientifique qui dit voilà l'état du
stock et voilà ce qu'on peut pêcher pour
permettre le renouvellement de ces
stocks et permettre d'avoir des poissons
pour les générations futures et le grand
défi qui est devant nous c'est de
d'allier le temps long c'est de se dire
qu'il faut maintenir des activités dans
un moment où l'espace maritime fait
l'objet de nombreuses utilisations de
nombreux usages nous allons devoir
développer des énergies marines
renouvelables des éoliennes en mer et
donc ça ça va être sur des zones parfois
où il y avait traditionnellement
historiquement des pêcheurs et donc il
faut aussi les usages en tout cas il va
falloir avoir une discussion sur la
planification planification non l'idée
c'est de dire et nous l'avons lancé la
semaine dernière on a un triple objectif
protéger nos océans donc nous allons
avoir des zones de protection forte
l'objectif c'est d'avoir 10% de zone de
protection forte sur toute notre espace
maritime nous avons déjà atteint les 33
% d'Hermann protégées mais nous devons
la plus loin sur les zones de protection
forte 2 c'est d'avoir permettre
d'activités économiques sur l'espace
maritime c'est notamment la pêche mais
c'est aussi l'aquaculture et
troisièmement c'est et bien de mettre en
oeuvre le déploiement des énergies
marines renouvelables 40 giga d'ici 2050
on a lancé le travail de concertation de
discussion avec les régions les
collectivités locales les pêcheurs les
ONG pour définir les meilleures zones
pour mettre ces éoliennes en mer parce
que ça va demander un vrai travail au
plus près du terrain de concertation
pour définir ces zones et atteindre ce
qui est une nécessité on l'a vu avec la
guerre en Ukraine une souveraineté
énergétique et on a la chance d'avoir un
façade et des façade littoral qui ont
des potentiels en éolienne et donc nous
allons faire ce travail de planification
qui a un travail aussi qui nous permet
au fond de ce projeter aussi sur les
questions d'adaptation au changement
climatique et de bien partir de la
science pour mettre en oeuvre des
politiques publiques et
autoriser ou non l'établissement de
telle ou toilettes avec activité une
canicule sévit en ce moment Brigitte
sans précédent autour des eaux du
Royaume-Uni donc la Manche est-ce que ça
vous inquiète est-ce qu'on peut se dire
que le ce Bulot là qu'on aime bien est
très mal barré quand même
alors je connais moins le cas de la
canicule à cet en ce moment
ils n'ont jamais été aussi chaudes mais
c'est le cas aussi spectaculaire
Méditerranée et c'est le cas dans vous
prenez une carte et c'est carte très
illustrative et qui nous montre la
nécessité d'agir de manière la plus
cohérente collective et urgentes et il y
a des canicules sous-marines et il y a
un réchauffement des eaux qui est
indéniable et donc Finistère
non non il fait une température parfaite
dans les eaux du Finistère encore plus
sur la Côte d'Émeraude mais c'est une
très bonne température mais la les
canicules sous-marine ou le
réchauffement des os un vrai problème
parce que c'est unduit justement ce que
vous disiez des disparitions d'espèces
ou pas donc c'est pour ça que
la priorité qui est la note notamment de
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique avec la décarbonation de tout
un tas de secteur aussi de protéger
un certain nombre d'habitats comme la
posidonie j'étais la semaine dernière à
Marseille parce que la France préside la
commission du développement durable pour
la Méditerranée et donc nous avons fait
de la protection de la polydonie c'est
quasiment une forêt amazonienne
sous-marine j'ai à peine et donc la
protection de la positionner c'est un
élément essentiel aussi parce que pour
la biodiversité marine et pour continuer
à avoir la richesse que nous connaissons
et des espèces qui vivent dans ces eaux
là et puis aussi la protection et ça
c'est vraiment une de nos priorités
également la protection des grands fonds
marins c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure nous devons protéger les grands
fonds marins parce que en fait nous les
connaissons que trop peu en tout cas de
ce que l'on connaît nous savons que ce
sont des écosystèmes fragiles qui sont
clés pour réguler le climat et clé dans
la biodiversité globale de notre planète
et donc la France est totalement opposée
à l'exploitation minière des fonds
marins parce que nous savons que sur les
3% à peine des grands fonds marins que
nous connaissons qu'il y a des espèces
très fragiles et donc nous avons une
ambition très forte sur la protection
avec notamment des programmes de
recherche on a mis 350 millions d'Euros
pour renforcer la recherche sur les
grands fonds marins parce que mieux
connaître c'est mieux protégé et c'est
une bataille diplomatique que nous
menons vraiment de chaque instant et
c'est ça le grand combat du siècle pour
la protection des océans c'est vraiment
l'interdiction de l'exploitation minière
des grands fonds marins alors maintenant
on va s'intéresser aux pêcheurs les
pêcheurs qui sont pénalisés par le
brexit faute de licence certains sont
contraints à l'abandon on en parle et on
met les pieds dans le plat
oui le brexit continue de faire du mal
au pêcheur français à ceux qui n'ont pas
eu de licence pour pêcher dans les eaux
britanniques tente d'obtenir des
indemnisations contre le démantèlement
de leur bateau mais certains navires
passent curieusement sous les radars
c'est le cas du chalutier de Loïc
pêcheur de Bulot reportage à
Boulogne-sur-Mer de Maïté Frémont et
d'André Lafont
je m'appelle Loïc on est au bassin
Napoléon derrière moi c'est mon bateau
mon grand-père aussi mon arrière
grand-père aussi c'est une histoire de
famille la famille de Loïc a toujours
travaillé dans les eaux anglaises pour
pêcher la sole puis le homard et en 2016
le bulot il y a 7 ans Loïc achète pour
850 000 euros ce chalutier avec ce
navire Loïc passe 75% de son temps en
mer britannique 2020 on commençait à
travailler ici
en journée on faisait une belle boucle
mais après le brexit son bateau
n'obtient pas de licence pour continuer
à faire cette boucle
[Musique]
j'ai perdu presque la moitié du chiffre
d'affaires passer d'un million à 600000
c'est pas ça aussi que chercher à m'en
débarrasser
se débarrasser d'un bateau trop coûteeux
c'est l'objectif de Loïc qui découvre
que les pêcheurs sans licence peuvent
bénéficier d'un plan mise en place par
le gouvernement une aide pour sortir les
navires de la flotte en contrepartie
d'une indemnisation le pêcheur dépose
donc un dossier mais contre toute
attente il reçoit une lettre de refus
avoir des intériorités entre 2012 et
2016 j'ai acheté le bateau en 2016 alors
comme je vous ai dit en 2019 j'avais 75%
montant dans les anglaises
et en 2018 j'avais 25%. donc même là à
25%, je passais dans les critères
j'avais tout tous les critères plus les
intériorités c'est un plan
d'accompagnement dû au brexit
nous servir
il y a 40 km quoi il y a rien même des
Bretons ils comprennent pas pourquoi moi
j'ai pas le droit quoi
Loïc n'est pas le seul à être dans ce
cas à Boulogne sur 18 bateaux seulement
6 ont été retenus au total en France 94
navires partiront à la casse
des hommes et des femmes engagés
passionnés et forcément quand il y a un
certain nombre de dispositifs on regarde
précisément au cas par individuellement
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai souhaité que
ce ne soit pas un plan de sortie de
flotte mais un plan d'accompagnement
individuel ce plan d'accompagnement
individuel je n'ai pas écrit sur le coin
d'une table d'abord il y a des règles
européennes qui sont très claires parce
qu'on est dans le cadre du brexit vous
l'avez dit et ça a été dit dans le
reportage il faut le brexit
la date que vous
connaissez et donc il fallait prouver
des antériorités entre 2012 et 2016 et
tout cela tous ces critères ils ont été
clairement écrits dans un arrêté qui a
été publié et co-écrit avec la filière
pêche en septembre 2022 et s'est arrêté
et l'objet a fait l'objet de
concertation de discussions avec tous
les professionnels de toutes les façades
maritimes concernées par le brexit donc
là il n'y a pas de surprise il y a pas
de surprise donc c'est ce que vous dites
je termine juste
rentrer dans le détail de cette personne
vous avez pas tous les éléments en tout
cas c'est juste une non c'est pas un
manque de questions
c'est comme quand vous voulez
postuler à quelque chose et des critères
définis on rentre ou pas dans ces
critères ensuite il y avait une liste de
navires qui rentrait dans les critères
et étant donné qu'on était dans une
enveloppe fermée il y avait des bateaux
qui pouvaient d'abord postuler si des
bateaux disaient finalement je veux pas
y aller ceux qui étaient dans les
critères et qui était sur les
complémentaires rentrez donc ça c'est
fait vraiment de manière transparente
avec la profession transparente avec les
professionnels et je n'a pas de chance
pour c'est pas une question de chance
c'est une question de juste avoir un
arrêté parce que sinon le problème si on
dit très bien on va lui donner il va
devoir rembourser l'Union européenne va
venir contrôler faire des audits et
faire rembourser à ce monsieur vous
serez les premiers à me dire mais quel
un conséquence comment que vous
organisez votre ministère cause c'est
les critères sont les critères et ça n'a
rien révisable en fait ministériel qui a
des discuté avec eux
c'est un arrêté ministériel qui a été
discuter avec la profession sur un plan
qui était d'abord demandé par la
professeur pour répondre aux
conséquences du brédit donc donner
navire qui avant le brexit péché dans
les eaux britanniques ensuite j'ai
entendu ce que était dit à la fin de ce
reportage qui doit nous interpeller
c'est pas la bonne manière d'apprendre
des choses et c'est pas la le pêcheur
qui le dit c'est la voix off qui dit sur
18 navires qui ont postulé il y en a que
6 qui ont été pris mais c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle de casser les navires ça veut
dire qu'on se prive de d'une production
et donc les navires qui n'ont pas été
retenus
les pêcheurs voulaient eux-mêmes se
débarrasser de leur bateau
tous ceux qui tous ceux qui rentraient
dans ces critères qui ont été encore une
fois discuter avec la profession pu
accéder à ce plan d'accompagnement
individuel il y avait ensuite quelque
chose de très transparent avec les vis
ça a été discuté pendant des semaines et
des semaines et donc cette situation de
ce monsieur je la connais bien c'est
c'est jamais heureux de voir des gens
qui pensaient pouvoir accéder à
dispositif qui ne l'ont pas mais je peux
vous dire que la priorité c'était de
faire face aux conséquences du brexit
donc justement les conséquences
dites-nous les conséquences du Brésil
largement les conséquences brexit pour
la peine quasiment 30% de la pêche
française qui était dû aux abritanniques
donc forcément
ça a des conséquences sur des navires
qui peuvent pas y aller d'où ce plan
d'accompagnement individuel et donc
maintenant ce qu'on doit faire est-ce
que je porte c'est de donner de la
visibilité au pêcheur sur notamment la
plus analynalité des quotas parce que on
ne peut plus avoir un système où chaque
année en décembre on a un conseiller
européen qui dit à ses pêcheurs on est
15 décembre au 1er janvier voilà la
quantité de poisson que vous pourrez
pêcher quelle entreprise fonctionne
comme ça donc moi je me bats et j'ai
réussi avec l'Espagne le Portugal et
d'autres pays à mené une coalition pour
que on commence à travailler sur la
purée annualité des quotas c'est à dire
qu'on donne de la visibilité sur ce que
les pêcheurs peuvent pêcher surplusonnés
et puis il faut investir sur la
transition énergétique des navires parce
que toutes les crises de la pêche
sont des crises qui sont liées au coût
du carburant puisque le biocarburant
de l'efficacité énergétique de réduire
le moins gros moment carburant avec des
méthodes aussi de navigation qui
permettent au fond la sobriété dans
l'éco-conduite comme on dit et puis
surtout de travailler sur des
technologies alternatives ça peut être
du biocarburant ça peut être de
l'hydrogène plus tard et donc on a
vraiment engagé ces travaux de
décarbonation puisque vous savez que
dans le cadre de loi climat résilience
tous les secteurs doivent avoir une
feuille de route de décarbonation nous
avons engagé le travail étant donné que
l'Union européenne ne nous autorise pas
pour l'instant à financer le
renouvellement de la flotte
à part les outre-mer où ils ont fait une
ouverture il y a des fonds privés qui
ont été débloqués par CMA CGM à hauteur
200 millions d'euros pour la
décarbonation du transport maritime et
de 20 millions d'euros cette année pour
le secteur de la pêche pour justement
lancer cette dynamique de décarbonation
et puis ce qu'il faut pour pardon pour
le secteur de la pêche on va passer au
dessert j'ai très faim vous savez les
crêpes c'est d'abord une odeur et donc
il faut aussi attirer des jeunes dans le
métier donc moi ce qui priorité c'est de
simplifier aussi parce que parfois il y
a des règles qui sont incompréhensibles
et qui qui désespèrent les jeunes de
rentrer dans le métier de il faut
montrer la diversité de ces métiers et
l'importance qu'ils ont pour notre pays
et donc on a relancé aussi la formation
maritime j'ai ouvert une formation
maritime en Guyane la toute première on
va ouvrir un lycée de la mer à la
Réunion j'ai été en novembre donc vous
voyez il y a une dynamique il y a des
gens qui rentrent dans le métier dans le
métier et il faut investir dans les
ports investir dans les ports avec les
régions les départements et la
collectivité locale c'est important
parce que si on a des navires il nous
faut des ports qui permettent la
transition énergétique et d'avoir des
biocarburants notamment allez on est on
est impatient de passer au dessert tout
le monde a fini c'est le péché mignon
alors je vais faire vite ce sont des
crêpes c'est ce qu'a demandé monsieur le
ministre des crêpes avec la confiture de
cerises on a bien compris que les
cerises étaient très important pour vous
tout à l'heure vous les congeliez donc
c'est sans doute un dessert je préfère
les manger c'est un très réglée
à la confiture de cerise c'est un
souvenir d'enfance ça peut prendre
autrement ça oui oui c'est d'abord parce
que les cerises c'est là c'était un peu
à cette période là où fin juin début
juillet ou on va les ramasser et c'était
ma première source d'argent de poche que
me fais c'était très peu mais en fait
nos grands-parents nous payaient
quelques euros c'était rien c'était
symbolique mais au kilo de de cerise
ramassées parce que c'est quand même un
faut aller dans l'arbre
et donc chaque fin de juin début été on
faisait ça avec ma sœur et on aura
ramassé le maximum pour ensuite faire
des confitures de cerises que ma
grand-mère faisait à la perfection que
ma mère aussi que mon frère et ma soeur
également
les crêpes
c'est d'abord une odeur vous voyez que
vous rentrez dans une cuisine moi
c'était souvent le samedi soir après le
basket auprès d'activité le samedi soir
c'est un peu la tradition vous avez
l'odeur de crème ensuite c'est un c'est
un geste
c'est un geste qu'on a ou qu'on a pas
qu'on oublie mais tout le monde a un
geste un peu différent et puis après
c'est une saveur c'est juste il y a rien
qui est égal je trouve une crêpe
[Musique]
merci Hervé Berville d'avoir accepté
notre amiibition merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivi rendez-vous bien sûr la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de politique à table sur LC